Welcome back to human emotion.
So today we're going to talk about touch.
So touch is something that is woven into
our daily exchanges with other people.
We have pats on the back,
handshakes,
hands resting on someone's shoulders,
a playful nudges.
And one of my favorite things,
hugs and touch her is this funny
thing because we do it all the time,
but we've seen to barely notice it.
It just kind of comes and
goes in our everyday life.
Yet we know that touch plays a profound
role on the kinds of feelings and
emotions we have,
but yet how precisely does it do it?
In what way can touch, not only
communicate our feelings to other people,
but actually being
touched by another person.
Change the way that we profoundly feel
about the world and about the people
around us. So what's in
a touch, so to speak, um,
touches something that seems not only
to be the fabric of our everyday life,
but something that is really pervasive
in a lot of creative works that we
generate. So we have songs, you know, by
one of my favorite bands, the Beatles, uh,
such as I want to hold your
hand. We also have, um,
other songs, um, that are, uh,
classics perhaps in a different way,
um, by Mc Hammer who said, you know,
you can't touch this, right?
So we see touches this topic
of many songs and music.
Um, we also have entire industries, um,
devoted exclusively to touch.
So such as this whole massage industry
where people will pay loads of money
simply to have someone rub their neck
and shoulders and these sort of luxurious
spa centered around
this phenomena of touch.
Yeah.
Right.
So really what is touch about,
so I'd like you to think about in this
touch reflection exercise we have here
about a time you can remember feeling
touched by someone close to you.
And I want you to think about what
was going on when this was happening.
So what sensations did
you have in your body?
What kinds of thoughts were
going through your mind?
What expressions did
you have on your face?
And did you notice after this touch,
maybe it was a hug like you can see here,
did you notice any changes in your
level of tension or stress? So again,
I want you to take out a piece of paper,
pause the video for a moment and write
down your thoughts to a time you can
remember feeling touched
by someone close to you.
And when you're done you can hit play
and we'll continue with the course.
And I want you to keep this example in
your mind throughout the rest of the
class today.
So today
we're going to really delve into this
idea of touch and is it some sort of
contact high?
Do we get this kind of rush of adrenaline
and excitement when we are touched by
others? Does it bring us close to
them and what does it do for us?
Okay,
we're going to go through this road map
today about touching by talking about
the function of touch,
that it's rewarding for us and that it
can actually sue this and calm our stress
levels. That it actually increases
cooperation between people,
that it helps us communicate our emotions
simply by touch without speaking or
doing anything else.
And we'll conclude with our takeaway
questions and our expert interview today.
So let's start with the ways in which
touch actually feels good for us.
So here we know that touch is actually
rewarding for us and there's a few ways
in which it is that is
actually this rewarding.
So one of them is that it
actually stimulates activity
in brain regions such as
the orbital frontal cortex that has
been scientifically demonstrated to be
associated with the encoding of reward,
value and greater activity in the
OFC is associated with people's self
reporting, feeling more pleasant,
um, and, and a sense of reward.
So touch actually gets your
brain activated to feel good
related to this.
Um,
studies have found that when you touch
someone on the arm with a velvety cloth,
something as simple as that or a light
hairbrush that it also activates or
triggers increases in activity in
the orbital frontal cortex as well.
So touch is rewarding in a very primitive
biological sense that it activates
neural regions that are,
we're sort of built and hardwired with
to tell us when something's rewarding or
when something feels good.
Touch is also soothing.
So it helps us sort of decrease stress.
It helps us calm down and in what
ways can touch actually be soothing.
So as you see here,
um,
touch a soothing insofar as it relates
to changes in hormones that are related
to our sense of stress or our
sense of love and connection.
So Cortisol is something that we've all
probably heard of and has been thought
of as the stress hormone. So Cortisol
is associated with increased reports,
a feeling negative effect, as well
as feeling stress. By contrast,
we have oxytocin and this has gained a
lot of popular media attention and is
thought of as the quote love hormone.
So had,
has been associated with feelings of love,
trust, and closeness with other people.
How does touch relate to
cortisol and oxytocin?
Will we actually find that when people
underwent a 15 minutes Swedish massage,
um, and during the massage they drew
blood while receiving this massage.
They found that even though you're having
blood drawn by simply going through a
15 minute massage, you see increases
in these hormone levels. Um,
it's particularly oxytocin, yet you
see a decrease in horror and cortisol.
So you see spikes up in a love hormone
and spikes down in a stress hormone
touches also soothing in other ways.
So here we turn to a different
brain region called the Amygdala.
So the Amygdala is located deep within
the medial temporal lobes of the brain.
And activation in this brain region of
the Amygdala is associated with stress
and negative emotional responses.
Again,
let's look at a study here
that was associated with
touch between two people. Um,
so this is one of my favorite
studies done by Jim Cohn,
who looked at individuals who are waiting
electric shock while they were in an
Fmri scanner.
So the participants were 16 married
women who came to the scanner and in the
scanner they were in one of three
conditions. They were alone by themselves,
all lonesome in the scanner.
They had a stranger holding their hand
while they were in the scanner and they
had or, or they have their husband
holding their hand in the scanner.
And what they actually found is
that having someone hold your hand,
decreased your activity in the Amygdala
more so than having no one holds your
hand.
So the having someone's literally hold
your hand decreases activity in this
brain region associated with emotional
arousal and sometimes stress.
And this was particularly the
case for someone close to you.
So the husband handholding was the
one that was associated with the least
Amygdala reactivity
compared to all conditions.
So when we think of the Beatle Song we
talked about the beginning of today,
if I want to hold your hand,
well,
there's a lot of good reasons
to hold someone's hand.
It actually decreases your stress
response to a variety of things, um,
in the scanner when you're
receiving an electric shock.
And you can imagine in everyday life to
helping you sort of combat and overcome
daily life stressors.
Okay.
So we also see an infants that touch
actually helps them overcome this very
painful procedure.
So when infants are young,
they do this extremely painful procedure
for sampling blood. So the infants,
while they sort of cut their foot
in a way to get this blood sample,
they studied this by having infants
who are either held or touched by their
mother during this procedure versus those
who were not held or touched by their
mother.
And they found that infants who were
touched by their mother cried 62% less.
They showed a decrease in the amount of
grimacing in their face by 65% and they
also exhibited a lower heart
rate during this procedure.
So touch also leads to better pain,
toleration,
even an extremely young infants.
So now we're going to turn to the way in
which touch also increases cooperation.
So here we find fascinatingly a study
that demonstrated how touch promotes
bonding and cooperation in groups.
So in this study,
participants are asked to sign a
petition supporting a local issue.
Those who are touched by the person
asking him to sign the petition.
A petition, um, had a higher rate
in which they actually signed on.
So 81% of people sign the petition who
were touched versus 55% who signed it
when they weren't touched.
Um,
another study looked at cooperation,
having people play what's called
the prisoner's dilemma game.
And in this game they can either cooperate
or compete with a fellow player and
the experimenter who uh, in the
condition, the experimenter,
either touch them on the back or
didn't before the game started.
And those participants were actually just
simply touched on the back. That's it.
Just a little touch on the
back by the experimenter.
Somehow that profoundly translated
into cooperating more on a completely
unrelated game.
There's also been additional work on
trust and cooperation by Dacher Keltner
who's looked at touch among NBA basketball
players and finding that basketball
players who actually touch each
other more sort of pats on the back,
things of that sort actually tend to
show better performance in a competitive
game situation.
So touch seems to increase and foster
cooperation among groups of people working
towards a common goal as well as
cooperation with unknown people.
So playing a game with someone you don't
know that you can cooperate or compete
with or signing a petition
with someone you don't know.
So touch is sort of the fabric that brings
us together as a society and helps us
cooperate. It's pretty amazing
what powerful things touch can do.
Finally,
I want to talk with you about some
really fun research that shows that just
simply touching someone's
forearm just like this,
that you can reliably communicate
distinct emotions. Wild,
right?
That without telling you how I'm feeling,
I can pat your arm or do a different
variety of gestures and you'll be able to
pick up on what emotion
I'm signaling to you.
So this is a study that
gain widespread attention.
You can see in the New York Times where
they say a simple five second touch can
convey specific emotions.
So I'll show you what this study looked
like. So here's the testing room.
So in this testing room,
there were two strangers who are asked
to sit down in the room across from each
other.
And as they sat down,
there was a black curtain that was drawn
in between them so that they couldn't
see each other.
But there was an opening here where
they could slip their arm under.
So one of the participants who was the
touchy was asked to extend his arm under
the curtain so that all this person
could see was the, the arm of the touchy.
Then this second person referred to as
the toucher was asked to think about how
you want to communicate the emotions.
The touches can take any form and last
as long as you think they need to try to
be expressive and as,
as possible in your touch.
So what happened is that
the toucher was asked to,
um, well there's the,
let's see how to put this.
So the touch one person put their arm
under the curtain, who was the, um,
toucher and then the touchy was asked
to sort of rate what emotion is this
person expressing. So, in other words,
it's two strangers sitting across from
another separated by a black curtain.
And the encoder,
so to speak,
touches the arm of the
decoder to express an emotion.
So one person puts their arm under the
curtain and the other person sees the arm
and asked to try to guess what that
person is trying to convey, right?
So when they're asked simply by looking
at the arm and someone touching it,
what emotion were they trying to convey?
You find powerful results that people
are able to not only convey an emotion
through a touch, but also pickup
what that emotion is. One,
another person is simply
touching their forearm.
And so what you find is people were given
a variety of emotions to convey, uh,
and also to try to perceive. So these
included negative emotions like anger,
fear, disgust, and sadness,
as well as more complex,
positive emotions like love,
gratitude and awe.
And what did we find
really quite fascinating?
So when they were asked to select which
emotion was being expressed by the touch,
and they had a variety, a
list of different emotions,
anger, fear, disgust, loves,
sympathy, gratitude, embarrassment,
pride and V, et Cetera.
When this person was asked to say
what was even being expressed,
they were able to profoundly and reliably
find touch to communicate distinct
emotions.
So touch communicates at least
six emotions including anger,
fear, disgust, love,
sympathy and gratitude.
And often some of the behavioral profiles
you see associated with these touches
are as follows.
So people would communicate,
touch on the forum by kind of doing
a trembling movement on the forearm,
or they would, um, communicate
love by simply say,
gently stroking the form of the other
person or gratitude by shaking their hand.
So we can convey emotions like gratitude
simply by touching someone's forearm,
if you can believe that. Um, at the same
time it doesn't communicate all emotions.
So touching the forum alone
couldn't communicate more cognitive,
complex cell focused emotions
like embarrassment, envy,
or pride.
But my God like the fact that we can
communicate touch simply by contacting
another person's arm without
seeing anything in their
face without your hearing,
any vocalizations is a profound,
uh,
example of the role of touch
in communicating, you know,
our everyday sentiments and feelings.
We've also found in our own work when
we've looked at touch and sort of clinical
or emotional disorders that not all
touches are alike. So, and work,
um, with some of my colleagues, Paul
Piff, Dacher Keltner and Amanda Purcell,
we wanted to understand whether people
who are characterized by heightened
positive emotionality.
So this is a clinical phenomena of mania,
whether they perceived touches using
the same paradigm in the same way or
whether people diagnosed are
prone to emotional difficulties,
actually perceived touches differently.
And what we found is that people who
have a history of mania or maybe prone to
experiencing mania,
I'm almost have these kind of rose colored
glasses in the way that they perceive
touches from another person.
So they are more likely to experience
emotions conveyed by the touches as
positive.
Um,
and they were less likely to experience
negative touches as negative.
So they felt more positive across all
touches and less negative across all
touches. And they were more
likely to attribute sort of um,
positive emotion even to negative
touches like anger or fear.
So although touch reliably communicates
emotions across most people,
we also want to think about the role of
individual differences of people with a
history of mania,
depression and anxiety for whom
communicating emotion via touch,
maybe slightly altered are different.
And this is something we'll return to
when we get to the module later in the
course where we talk about
emotion and psychopathology.
Okay.
And with that, I want to turn
now to our takeaway questions.
So from today I want you to think
about a few different things.
So first,
how can touch actually be a
source of pleasure or reward?
How can it feel good for us?
And likewise,
how can touch actually provide
soothing comfort in response to stress?
Okay.
Second, how might trust
increase or touch not trust?
How might touch actually
increased cooperation?
So provide an empirical example of
several that we spoke about in class.
Okay.
And then finally,
which specific emotions is touch most
effective in communicating to other
people? Simply by doing a
gentle touch on the forum.
What emotions can we signal
to other people around us?
And I want to conclude as usual
with our expert interview,
and this is part of the experts
in emotion interview series.
Okay.
So for this module of the course,
um,
are experts in emotion interview today
will be with Doctor Matthew Hurts and
sign. He received his phd from the
University of California Berkeley and he's
currently an associate professor of
psychology at Depauw University where he
directs the touch and emotion laboratory.
So his research is conducted with
students, um, in three areas,
including touch and the communication
of emotion as well as the prediction of
emotion and emotion and infants.
His work has received widespread
media coverage, including NPR,
the New York Times, ABC
News, BBC scientific,
American mind,
and psychology today.
So I now turn to our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Matthew Hurtin
sign.